Okay, evening. We are back
live.
Hello. Where did my chat window
go? There we
are. So, we have some uh some
experiments to check.
First of
all, this actually works perfectly
fine. Nothing wrong with uh our sweeps
at all. Takes, you know, three billion
steps or whatever to get off the ground,
but it's it's fine.
Now there is something wrong with our
sweep our sweeping function
because I just had a separate set of
experiments right
here in which I can replicate this
experiment that had a really good
hyperparams
uh but for whatever
reason couldn't didn't find them during
a
sweep. This is solving mazes. It's
really really good maze solving agent.
Probably soda maze solving
agent. And uh I just want to figure
out I just want to figure out why it is
that the sweep did not find these
parameter. No.
Start up
here. 16 m. Yeah, this is fine. 5V7 to
1810. BPT horizon of
64. Mini batch as low as
0007 entropies is
reasonable. Gamma lambda are fine.
Vrace row clip and V trace C
clip the clip
co
range co is
fine. So, I mean, all of these things
like look
reasonable, but then it still doesn't
find
uh these params in a big
sweep. Let me try very quickly. I just
want to see how much worse it
gets. 16
Reason I want to rerun this is because
it is possible that there's some quirk
where it's just very difficult for it to
sweep over
um this type of
parameter like this log space
parameter due to how the sampling math
works.
So, it could be that it just can't find
the small mini
batches. We shall see.
Oh yeah, so far that is not really
learning.
See? Meanwhile
though, our 200 run
example one the one that didn't work
super
well. I mean this actually does find
like a few
runs at 8192.
It's most likely eval or something
weird, right?
what? Oh, no. This is a different one,
right? Yeah, this is
I suspect that this is going to come
down to differences
uh minor differences made with this
sweep setup.
So this
does not
reset that we do not reset and then we
do 32
updates. How this one
goes. Uh now notably actually this is
doing pretty darn
well. So,
on. Okay. Like it's not it's not
anywhere near as good as
this. But like this is still better than
we what we found in the other sweep. So
it's not just mini batch size. It's not
just mini batch size as a parameter.
It's causing problems. I don't know why
I have these on.
So, we don't reset and then we do 32
updates of
Is there like a little spike at the end
or something
weird that like messes with
anything? Sort of compare the uh the
terminals
behavior. One of the things that matters
is how the sweep finishes.
So like uh this is the bad
one. Can we get this like small uptick
maybe at the
end? Yeah, it looks like there's Well,
it's not always an
uptick. Okay, but then like with this
one these things have the same
thing. Kind of have the same like
tick a little bit more
flat. Oh, there's still like a change.
They're both like
solid real time
There very very few things then that
this could
be could actually be different
here. Not a lot
Um yeah, let's suspect that
[Music]
the the sampling at the
end wrong
first. Like isn't there this down sample
alt? Okay, so
like Oh no, this has the last
Yeah. So, this actually
has last. The only thing that this could
be is the 10 samples. 10 samples versus
five,
right? Can't think of anything
else. Let's SSH in and try
it. Didn't I do that in this sweep,
though? I thought that I tried that.
Make sure I didn't already do that. 200
runs. Do like
this. Okay, we
change. Oh, we capped it at
288. That was probably pretty
Could it literally just be the time
steps? Like if we capped a
2E8 like it just did too many short
runs. I mean that's kind of jank if so,
but
here. 5 E7 to
6E8. I mean, that's naturally going to
make it more aggressive at the start,
maybe.
We're going to try both of those
changes. We'll see if that uh that
recovers it or
Okay. So, this is the
grid. This is 3.0 pre4. So, which is
going to be the the one that we're
Hello
Ky,
welcome. Wait, hang on. This says 57 to
68. Um, that doesn't crack, does
it? 5 E7 to
68. I thought I just looked at a
commit. Yeah, I literally This is
from the fifth
No, from the
31st config
ocean Pac-Man. Okay, this is in Pac-Man.
We don't care about
that. So, like, has this actually just
been fine?
5768. Well, then the only thing that
this could possibly be
is this going from 10 to five,
right? Maybe it needs 10 samples. I
don't freaking know.
We're not going to have to run it for
super long to find
out. What Linux do you use? This is
Abuntu. Pretty vanilla Abuntu as
well. I've used very many things over
the years, but this is now what I use.
At this point, the killer app for the
killer app for Linux that would get me
to switch distros or whatever are
drivers that consistently
work. All I
want, drivers that actually consistently
work.
building? Upper.ai for demos, my friend.
Ultra high performance reinforcement
learning. We have tiny neural networks
that are training on like hundreds or
thousands of years worth of games and
are solving all sorts of problems like
in
seconds. You can watch a bunch of neural
nets playing games in your browser here.
Not just games, but we use a lot of
games because they're great for
testing.
So, I mean, we know from these things
now. We've got neural MMO 3. Actually, I
haven't
run I do not remember the last neural
mmo3 curve that I
ran. I should probably look at that real
quick. That's cool. Thank you.
I think so as
tracking. Little different actually from
any of the other
curves. I don't mind leaving this on
overnight just
running. See what it does.
The thing is we are totally at a point
where we should just be able to do like
a five bill
run. For whatever reason doesn't seem to
work super well.
this? I wonder if there's an initial
condition
problem. Like hang
on. If I just
Go look at these ones. This was the good
one,
right? I mean, there's like a first run
scrolling, but like I wonder if the
first run just was way better in this
one for whatever
reason. No, they look the same,
right?
Go up to 0 2 down a little bit. Yeah,
very similar PF.
issue. If I go like eight of
these, one of these actually does pretty
well. If I do like two pages of
these by 16 runs, no, it's actually
still not like amazing.
Okay. So, you start to get runs like
when you get like 20 runs deep, you
start actually like getting some stuff
that's not
terrible, but it's not great. That's
really not great
either. So, I wonder if
um I wonder if it is literally just like
the 10 samples versus five thing.
H bit irritating. If so, I definitely
should have been more careful with uh
not breaking this benchmark because this
one is so good.
Like can we just take a moment here to
models. I'm trying to think what the
good like what a good plan is here.
I think neural
MMO3 is going to be a good target end
for testing DDP because it's got a
really long train curve that we know how
to like that we know that we should be
able to
match. So like we'll run this tonight
and then tomorrow when we get the
machines we'll try
I guess I could go check in on Spencer
and how he's doing with
uh drones. I mean, not drones,
terraform.
yard a potential fix. Let me go take a
quick look.
Okay, so this guy's actually making more
M's as well. That's great.
So yeah, you kind of committed
uh different stuff in there, my
guy. That's fine. It's just voids
things. You should probably take a look
at the uh the new like go take a look at
the code for the convert environment for
voids by the way. Like I figured that
when I was doing that end like that
would also help you out a
I just had a hummingbird do the most
bizarre aerial acrobatics display I've
ever
seen.
Okay. Cool things about having a bunch
of wildlife outside the
window. But yeah, plasma, just check out
um the convert environment. When I was
writing it, I figured it would be a good
reference for you as well. Like I knew
you were already doing voids, but you're
having like a tough time getting stuff
to train. So I figured that would be a
good reference M. And we're all the for
reference, by the way, like we're going
to be doing a lot more swarming type M
soon. So that type of stuff is actually
quite
Wait. Yo, how's this make any sense,
man? Autotype is a function.
pointer, but that's not the type. This
doesn't get called,
function. Yeah, but that's cuz Python's
a stupid language,
right? Well, this this has this check in
here, right? So you it would just be
autotype, wouldn't it?
Well, I'll merge this for now. So, thank
you. I might make some changes to
it to 3L. Thank
you. Any reason not to?
Thank you for
that. Okay, so this is definitely not
the same here cuz I just had 16
runs and I didn't get a single good run.
Whereas like over
here, this is like 16 runs and I'm
already getting like this. You can see
it's dramatically
different. So
what what is possibly different here?
You got to be a little careful with that
like so that the way you convert is not
rounding floats to
ins. You could very easily cause a lot
of problems with
that. If you like are rounding float
parameters to int
parameters by
mistake. I have no idea, man. Why Why do
you think I would know like dumb Python
details? Does this work? No. Look at
that. Okay. Okay. But like if you try if
you do int first in the
loop. Oh, cuz it's
uh
wait. Oh, that's terrible. You can't
possibly tell me this is good language
design,
right? So, int of 2.3 is error. Int of
two is a string is two. Int of 2.3 is
What the hell?
I don't even want to use that because I
didn't even know Python does that.
That's freaking
terrible. What a [ __ ]
language. Like the thing is the reason
that Python is not always a bad language
relies on you not doing that.
horrifying. Can do is we can rewrite the
entire thing in C including PyTorch.
maps? Could there actually be that big
of a difference just in the number of
maps?
I mean, there's no point in not just
like checking,
right? Cuz like it's clearly not working
as
is. I mean, we'll we'll just check one
last thing before I kill this and rerun.
But
like, yeah, this is not work. Like, this
is not close to comparable.
Okay. Like this is the only other thing
I could
think, different number of maps.
That'd be so weird though if like you
actually needed that many thousand maps
to
scale. All right. That'd be like
wonky. I mean, you did numb M is 4096
and then like config
default was two, right? Two.
So, uh, this should end up with 8192
total
M's. And like, I'm not stupid, right? I
didn't have like a different number and
just not see
it. No, because this
repros, right? So like this
repros and that repros with eight M's
41. So then it can't even be the numb
maps cuz I reproed with
4096. So, this sweep that I just started
is
worthless. What the heck else would it
be?
commits? Oh, I should just make a PR, I
guess, right?
differences. I mean, there's some sweep
differences
technically. Like, hang on. I see this
VF clip collifs difference.
So, like maybe if I look down here and
it's all shitty VF
clip. I mean, that's like one, two,
three, four, five runs with bad VF clip,
right? It should still work with
that. Only a quarter of the runs that
have dumb VF clip.
changes. Can I find like a sweep.py
maybe or demo.py
My input equals
That's fine. That's just a
rate. Didn't have min score and max
score before,
rate break point.
Yeah, this is exactly the same. There is
literally zero
difference. Okay, so
like there's
bunch, but I don't know if it changed in
any way that
matters. I mean, we're running out of
possible things that could break it,
so presumably it could be something in
here.
The five and 10 here is the main big
difference.
I mean, could it have been an endbinding
screw-up
potentially? That would be really
bizarre,
right? It actually can't even be an
endbinding screw- up. You know
why? Cuz the hyper still work.
Got to be a sweep screw up somehow,
right? Could it be a logging change mess
up
somehow? Like maybe the way that in
which we're logging is producing less
stable estimates or some
[ __ ] would be like
really that would be sus.
um any sort of change to the way that
logger is implemented, right?
see. Not this
either.
Was it really not that? Cuz I'm like out
of things that it could be.
I thought that this like we had this
greater than 20% thing, didn't we? Like
this was already in there.
And yes, this is this is literally
already there.
I guess I like I could try
this. Like it's technically possible
this breaks it. I give it like a one in
20 at best.
I'd be very very surprised. Like I'd be
so
surprised. I literally have these two
side by sideed.
end. Am I just like trolling on the
sweep thing and not seeing
Input equals
hypers. Input equals self
suggestion. Is this even in like the
same spot though?
Yeah. No, this is in the random sampler,
dude.
260. Nobody cares about that.
Well, like there's this max and min, but
we already just didn't have these,
right?
changes. Is the expansion rate exactly
the
same? Yes, it
is. That is weird, man.
That's
weird. Oh, there was an apps deleted,
but I don't
think I think the apps was deleted
because there is no use for an apps,
right? Yeah, the apps was deleted
because it's not being used.
trying to think what I could have
possibly
broken. It was very
odd. Like all the things that I can
think of that I might have messed with,
I already checked and I didn't mess with
them.
well. I mean, I think we got to go into
like
paranoid like paranoid mode
and I think it's literally just like
changing a mean
param. It'd be weird because like the
mean value was reasonable. I
believe that'd be so
weird. I guess stranger things have
happened.
Let's look for other
possibilities
meantime. Oh, you know
what? Kill this
paranoid. Okay. So, if that doesn't
match, then there's some some demons
inhabiting this code
base. I have to get out the holy water
and
the I don't know what else demons don't
like. Ion
cannons. We'll get some of those
Those are all the thoughts I
have. This does not work yet. I don't
know. Sweep seems
identical. Oh, would have to be some
like logging quirk
change. Well, I guess technically, hang
on. if I screwed with the way that
logging
grid.py. I guess technically it could be
a log change, but like I I don't think I
did anything weird with that. I really
don't would make more sense as like a
mean M's [ __ ]
thing. I still don't see how this would
change it though.
Like this would like this would almost
be just as weird if it were
this. I mean that's slightly different
but not statistically different I'd
imagine, right?
What did I change the means
to? Didn't I change it to something that
like shouldn't matter at
all? Like I changed the default
innies instead of having uh 8 M's what
is it? No, eight M's mean two mean of
two M's that have 4096 each. I changed
it to a mean of eight M's that have 1024
each. Like I guess
technically it's technically different.
The mean point is the same though. And
all the good runs are also in both of
these. That would be so weird, man.
So weird,
this? I mean, that's like meaningfully
different
already. We're going to actually let
this run for a bit and then we're going
to back check
everything and back check everything.
If I just look at like numbum M's or
whatever the hell
here it's all on two, right?
And then like if I go
four. It could just be too many wasted
runs, you know? Well, like they're
mostly clustered at eight.
I don't know how that
happens. Like the type of bug that would
have to exist for this to be a thing is
very
especially because like I know that you
can run the exact same params with the
other config and it
works. Like I would suspect like an
environment bug or something, but no.
It's something related to the way these
distributions get sampled. I
guess like I got five runs on here
versus over here.
Whoops. I go seven runs.
got four runs on it. It could just be
like a stickiness thing, you
know, like having the lower range is
just sticky to eight.
I mean, this is kind of what I get for
not having random seeds. I mean, like
not having I should clarify that. So,
like normally you seed um hyper pram
sweeps by doing like a few just uniform
random samples, but the problem with
that is uniform random is sampling just
sucks for hyper pram sweeps. So, we just
don't do it.
um it like can help with stuff like
this, but even then technically that's
not even
guaranteed. Yeah, like we've got already
we've got some decent runs. I mean, I
could just be looking at noise still to
be fair, but like
It went
from Let me make sure I did this
correctly. This
way. Okay.
So, Max got changed from 8 to 16 and
then me went from two to eight and it
broke.
That was the only other real change I
made here, wasn't it?
that and returning the number of M's
like num ms to
4096 I mean I guess those are
substantially different ranges
right like on one of these you have one
vecend like one env
is going to be 1024 agents and the other
one is going to be 4096 agents and then
the top end is going to be 32k versus
16k. So even though the means are the
same, it does change the
sampling process a bit because
like okay if you have like let's say you
have your mean of two and then you
sample a one you still have 40 96
agents right and if you sample like a
four then you have 16k agents whereas
with
16 an eight mean like you could sample
two and you only have 2k agents.
like when you have a mean of two, you're
towards the bottom end of the
distribution. So like you're more likely
to sample upwards, I
guess, whereas in the other one here,
you're likely to sample
downwards. I mean, this is such a subtle
change, though. Like, they should not be
breaking
things. And I mean, we don't even really
necessarily know that it does for sure
either. Like, for all I know, this could
still be
broken. But like, if I go look
at like how much better is this sweep
here? This is like 16 experiments. you
start to get
some. But like it takes a little while,
right? Like if I just turn off some of
these
now So this is the last page of results.
One, two, three, four.
So, we had one of these get like
decent and then we have
like mostly
lower. You got your breakout
runs
in, but there's RNG to
that. Okay. Okay. So, like getting a
point
4. I still think that this is good
[Music]
because this
here. Yeah. Here I have 20 runs and I
never get a
point4. And actually, I don't I have
only one over two.
Yeah. So like pretty high confidence I
would say that this is materially
different.
Bizarre. Oh, now I kind of have to run
like multiple of these annoyingly long
sweeps,
huh? Fine. That'll be the goal for
tonight and we'll be to figure this out.
You
know, breakout
params. Be willing to bet that
the optimals for breakout were not found
here. It was probably
found 4096 and four.
go verify that real
Pro tip, if you advertise your UI based
on speed, actually make your UI
fast. Like, okay, so there's some runs
in here, but
like they don't actually full solve, I
don't
think. They're like close, but no cigar.
Then we
have guy. Stop
that. Got these
[Music]
reason. So, this is a 24 second
here. Pretty sure it's
commit as
before.
basically. So somehow this is how we got
sub
point4? I have it like virtually
identical here.
I didn't add like any other defaults or
anything either. It is straight up just
this this and then
grid any
again. It repros. That's the weirdest
thing. It's not like I broke some other
thing and now the run doesn't repro. It
repros perfectly, but the sweep doesn't
find
it. And it's not like broken sweeps
either. It actually will sweep and like
find decent enough runs, but they don't
look the same, do they?
Maybe it is a log frequency [ __ ]
thing. Let me
grid. These are how different these
sweeps look,
chaotic. But so are
these. I mean, we immediately we notice
the difference in
length. 100 mil. Yeah. See, this has way
more long
runs. Seven. And then this gets to one
almost.
see. Apparently this is two separate
sweeps.
shenanigans
173. Yeah. So, this like never ran
anything expensive at
all. Like at all at all. Never ran
anything
expensive. And then this thing
Why does it look like time steps caps at
mil? It doesn't.
Right. It says 6E8 right
there. It never uses it
E8. Also got these two score
curves. again if I like fix
mean, well, it's very
different. This is getting 0.9 like
really soon even,
right? It's like in the first hour and a
half of sweeps.
a.m. Wait,
12. Yeah. So, they both take 10
hours. Kind of weird with how some of
those runs are like way shorter.
810 or rather let's go to 8:20. We do 1
2 3 4 5
6 7 12 16
runs by 8:20 p.m. That actually looks
reasonable runs by 8:20 p.m. So we go 20
minutes ahead is going to be like
here 16. Yeah, now these are
reasonable. There's not like some jank
timing difference.
you'd kind of expect there to be, but
there isn't
So weird if it was logging stuff because
like the curves are fine, right?
Yeah, like you reproduce the smooth
curves as well.
This down sample is the same. We didn't
change it.
nothing. It can't be an error with the
end
because because they're run
repros, but I don't see a difference
with the
hypers search.
Right. I mean, like technically though,
right? Could it be?
N man, this is like it's too big of a
difference to just be RNG.
longer. Probably because of
this. Like it is running stuff for a
little
I'm trying to think what's the
likelihood that I have a screw up versus
what is the likelihood that it's just
very fiddly.
Okay. I
bet the GPUs are should be here
tomorrow. Got slightly
delayed. The problem
is the sweep the sweep results. They're
still working, but they're not matching
the previous sweep results. So, I'm
trying to see if I changed anything in
sweep defaults. And I changed a few very
minor things, but I like it doesn't seem
to make a huge
difference. But I'm trying to figure out
what are the odds that like the sweeps
are just kind of fiddly and like, you
know, maybe sometimes it takes 200 runs,
sometimes it takes 400
runs versus
um like did I actually break something?
The thing is that before now there has
to be a difference because
better that like this thing doesn't work
now. this thing
here. This has got to be like 50 runs
that it takes to get this
score. Like the sampling is somehow
dramatically
like it is solving before it gets to
some ridiculous number of steps. First
and second. So this is the good one.
And this is the bad
7. Give
score four score.
I mean the point is this one this is a
178 run sweep. Look you can see that
within 50 or so experiments it's like
0.98
whatever. And this one here it gets up
like it first of all has a bigger
cluster at the bottom that just suck and
then it doesn't really get above this 7
mark.
Well, these aren't curves. Each one of
these points is a
why a
curve?
Yeah, a curve.
curve. Lost is the number of seconds the
experiments takes to run.
creation
time. Oh, this thing. Yeah,
like this is just me seeing how it like
it uses more compute over the course of
a run. If you want like the PTO
front, which technically it's two sets
of experiments here.
Um, but like if you want the burrito
front like this would be versus time
steps here.
else? Yeah, I I I did that,
man. I've checked all of it.
both before and after. What What's that
going to
do? The runs
reproduce. They always reproduce. In
fact, here's the crazy thing, right?
What? Why does my ISO not work? There we
So I like here's the thing that I
literally I can run the optimal hypers
from the old sweep and the the curve
Plasma. How would the curve produced,
but not the
sweep. Like, I'm pretty damn sure we
haven't messed with the
sweep. Like, I looked at this
like, so first of all, this is for
random search.
Like, this doesn't freaking matter.
We didn't mess with hypers up here,
right? This is just added here from hard
coding. Did I mess with it and
anything. They shouldn't be affected
this much,
like these just get set to
max. Yeah. 1.25. Look. So this is this
versus one plus expansion rate.
Expansion rate is 0.25. 25.
run the before
sweep. I guess I can. It's like
obnoxious, but it's
I don't know. There might be a max
puffer limit. You never know, man.
this. How wonky would it be if it were a
binding change?
here like according to this that branch
doesn't even run.
Yeah. Like this probably just didn't
have a close function
here. But technically it does.
But it probably just didn't do anything
before, right? Like I think it was just
like
this. I think what probably happened is
like close.
Like I think I just have this [ __ ]
commented.
Okay. How the hell is this still a thing
where this is
like complaining?
remember. It's probably not copying it.
This is before I fixed the
I mean, I could go try to fix this egg
fault. I don't think it's
related. So, grid doesn't like it when
you close
it. I didn't notice it before because we
weren't calling close.
But like that problem was
in it was in the old
version. Why is it so bright all of a
sudden here? Let's see.
There.
Better. Maybe a little more.
see like this doesn't look amazing
either. If we give it more runs, it
should repro,
right? If it doesn't, then I don't know
what to think.
If it doesn't, then I'm just going to
have to fiddle with it and launch a
bunch of different weird
sweeps. I mean, there's probably like
some conclusions we
can we can make already, right? Cuz like
don't we
have we have like this
have
here like we
rate bad norm.
They're pretty varied hypers to be
honest with
you. I mean the enduro clip is kind of
awkward. Can't really tighten the ranges
up.
like I'm looking for like hyper pram
ranges to tighten up or something, but
like it doesn't look like I can even do
that.
[Music]
I mean, I could totally mess with the
means a bunch, right? Like, I could push
the means towards like stuff
that's closer to the defaults.
it. Maybe I should look at the means.
Maybe that's better.
And this got swept as well, right? The
BPT
this. Let's see. We ran with this on
auto sleeping
Yeah. So, this is a good this is a good
run
here. For some reason, it doesn't show
the
diff. Okay. So, this actually tells me
then
changes. So maybe I got to go up a
couple
No, wait. This is
19 and
It's not this one, right? Yeah, this is
the [ __ ]
one. This
one. The
1D. Okay, so here it is.
Use final
EST. And that's all I did
here was use final est. It's just this
small little fix.
And we're already doing this
on Oh, well, this is not actually
working either, now is
Now I'm starting to wonder because the
sweep result doesn't
repro. The runner repros but not the
sweep
result. If I had to choose one of the
two to repro, at least I got the better
of the
And like it's very weird because we can
clearly
see this is the 178
run. We can clearly see the max total
time steps and min. They were set
correctly.
999. Pretty darn
good. Pretty darn good.
on. Keep pushing, my dude. Super excited
about your work. Godspeed. Thank
you. It's almost there, man. It's just a
couple last bugs and experiments and
things. It's a lot of work.
there. I mean, there's the value
function clip coefficient being kind of
unhinged.
on.
Ah, okay. Hang
on. Maybe that tells a different story.
rate. Probably cuz the mini batch size
is small.
Oh, no. It's a bigger policy. That's why
the learning rate's smaller. Duh.
Neptune. Come
on. We're aware of the
issue. I like how they just We're by
default. Yeah, we're aware of the issue.
Our service page, it says it's perfectly
good.
be. Servers are overloaded or some
[ __ ] Uh yeah, it actually just
straight up stopped logging as well
because there's no more runs in there.
That's kind of
I mean, this is kind of an interesting
question, right, of like what I
do when
um when I'm confronted with something
like this where I've checked
everything very very precisely.
I know numm's changed, man. I've tried
it both ways. And in this change, we
also changed um first of all, this one's
the breakout uh commit. And when we did
this, we also changed env.
So we multiplied vecum ms by four and
divided num ms by four. And I also I
tried it both ways as
well. I mean I'm leaning towards just
like
do take
status not just random Bad.
Okay. So, I think what I'm leaning to
do, we're going to just try some yolo
[ __ ] 9:25. I'm getting
tired. I'm going to try some yolo [ __ ]
That's going to kill my neural MMO run,
isn't
it? Neptune.
bug. Hey, it's Ben,
sir. Trying to track down some like
inconsistent with sweeps. How's it
going? and chat briefly about Terraform
if you
want. I'm just trying to figure out what
the hell's wrong with this
Spencer. For some
reason, the sweeps are not doing uh like
they're still working, but they're not
doing anywhere near as well as they were
before. And I can't figure out why
because the code's like
identical. So, I've been trying to sort
that out.
I got like initial distributed training
running. Um I have to obviously like do
some tests. So, I'm like I'm getting a
default just a run of neural MMO without
that to see if we can replicate on like
multiple cards. Uh
first, uh if I could get distributed
sweeps running actually
technically. I mean, we should be able
to do
like this thing should be like 200
billion a day or something crazy like
that. Maybe like 150 on the
4090s. So we should be able to really
crank some
experiments. What advantages are we? It
just it trains like virtually like a
multiple of the number of GPUs that you
have faster.
the cap that wasn't there with your
agents.
You know, it's actually one thing that
we probably should fix. Actually, here I
You know what? I here This is totally
it, man.
Um yeah, I I don't know how I screwed
this up, come to think of it. Uh, for
the pearl and
noise, get a random
number. Add like a random number. You
might have to play with the range of the
random number that you add, but add a
random number to the the offsets.
There's like offset
pars. Oh, you've already done
that. Oh, did you already tell me that
you did that?
Okay, my bad. Yeah.
So, okay. It's totally training on all
the same maps. So, that's probably
it's Yeah. Okay. That's major. That's
major
major. Um, we're good. Good. go
up his neural MMO
lately pretty
good. Hey
Gabe, we are on stream for reference.
Yeah, we're good. Uh I
am trying to figure out what the hell
with
sweeps. It's just a bit jank, you
know. Oh, this is so funny. Like
MMO and then this tiny little
experiment. I
mean like technically that's a little
better than before.
uh just like how quickly like it within
nine experiments it's found a few runs
that this
um basically I like the sweeps are
working worse than before and I can't
tell if like there looks like there's no
code difference so I can't tell if it's
just fiddly because of the default
sampling ranges or if I actually broke
something but I like meticulously went
through every line of the diff and I
can't find anything. Apparently, people
can't hear. Hang
on. You can't blame me
when for no reason whatsoever
uh it just decides to do that. Say
something, somebody.
What's up? Yeah, there we go. You guys,
you can't blame me when it just switches
devices randomly for no reason on me.
Haven't plugged or unplugged anything.
It's just dumb.
Linux drivers.
Yeah, I don't even think it's Linux
drivers. I think it's just the programs
just like having shitty ways that they
pick up defaults.
Do you think there's any
benefit to telling an agent where the
other dozers are at? Might be.
Because the only weird situation I could
see happening is
like all of each all the agents go to
the same area and try and extract dirt
from the same point.
sweep. I kind of just want to find like
a param that works like relatively well
so I don't have to just keep on sweeping
every time I make a new change.
Um, well, it kind of depends how much
you change the end.
Well, yeah. I mean, if I change ops, I
mean, I'm pretty sure I have to sweep
again. I'm also just a little bit
suspicious of like some of the sweeps
lately.
Um, if we get this working and then I go
and I run breakout and pong and those
still work then
like I think decent
few.3s. I do know that sometimes I've
been able to manually screw with params
a little bit to get more optimal stuff
on GPU drive before
which you shouldn't be able to do. So
it's
like I just like tweak the reward a
little bit. The crazy thing here is that
the hyper prams repro perfectly. This
it's the sweep that doesn't. So I have
this like god set of grid parameters
that uh repros and gets you it's like
98% on 48x 48
like maze like maze
agi but uh
it like somehow we can't get it
consistent like finding that set of
params or hypers.
Yeah. Yeah. I I've experienced something
similar GPU drive. Like I I would get
like a really good set of stuff and then
if I try to run a different sweep after
like the most minor of tweaks, it would
like really struggle to find that same
one it found in a previous
sweep. Was there Pac-Man merge, Gabe?
Uh yeah. Um, I did make some progress
though, but
uh I think there's still improvement to
be made. Um, I kind of got to like
a I got one model learning better than
it was, but I also added just like a ton
of prams to the model size. And I feel
like you shouldn't have to train seven
billion steps on Pac-Man or whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. I saw that seven billion
message. That was wild. But you got good
performance though. Yeah. Yeah. I mean
it it it uh it looks pretty good. Have
you run a sweep?
I I have not run a sweep. Okay. Cuz I
swept cuz I got I showed you the model I
got from Pac-Man. And this was the old
version before you changed the mechanics
to make it like actually doable. I did
change the mechanics. So, like on the
old version of
Pac-Man, I got 200 experiments for
you. And we got I think this one didn't
repro. So, this like actual PF was like
I think this is like 160 170ish
range before you made it easy. But like
you can see the disparity here in all
these runs.
Yeah, that's a pretty wide range. So,
like the point here is if you're just
like using some defaults,
right, you should just run sweep.
Yeah. No, I I think I think I could you
could definitely do a lot better than
what I got. But at least it was
progress.
Yeah. So, if if any observations made it
better, then maybe it's, you know, the
current observations are not sufficient
also.
I I feel like the current observations
like they might be like technically
sufficient
but not ideal.
If more information you have relative
position to ghost or ghost's position.
Yeah, sometimes weird stuff helps like
that. What does it's all uh Yeah, it's
all absolute. Yeah. So like relative
position to ghost ghost speed relative
position to dots.
It's like oh speed's a constant. Why do
I have to do like Yeah. Sometimes it No,
that can't be a thing. But I Yeah, I
don't know about that one. That's called
its curse, dude. That's You're adding a
bias term there. So like you already
have a bias term.
Yeah, there's just no way. It's like
tuning, right? There's just no you might
have like you just might have jiggled a
knob that happened to be like the thing
is you might have jiggled a knob but
there's no way that like generally you
have to add an observations of [ __ ]
constants. Yeah. No, generally
definitely not. Um fairly certain that's
just like jiggling like like you could
have just added a random number to there
and it can't tell the difference like
enduro has it though. Just
saying just like it's mathematically
impossible.
I
mean, maybe there are things we don't
understand about neural networks,
Joseph. Maybe there are things you don't
understand. No. No, we totally don't
understand. We totally don't understand
things about networks. We totally don't.
All right. Head of rest, I kid. I
understand that. Hear me?
Gabe, is your obs to Pac-Man the whole
world? Yes. Uh, but it's all as um kind
of like one one big vector. It's not
there's no like spatial structure to the
observation, which might be part of the
problem or why it's why it's hard to
learn. like it's just one big like
linear layer of however many like like I
don't know everybody doing like classes
like are you did you do one hot thumb or
whatever?
So
um the pickup like the pickup things is
just one
um
yeah like Pac-Man's like zero and like
Ghost is like two and like you could try
our policy
is like
like our 11 by1 11 comp policy is pretty
darn good. Yeah, I I feel like at this
point that's worth trying out. Pretty
easy and like there's so many code
samples for it. Yeah, I mean like puffer
can like puffer the thing is like puffer
just does such crazy things. It's like
Tougher does such crazy things at this
point that when like things are not
learning, we start asking questions
about the environment more than
anything.
Yeah. And it's good to I'm skeptical of
the environment, too. Um,
look at all them puffers.
I think I'm I think I'm most skeptical
of the
observations.
Um, but if you train train it for a
really long time, it can still kind of
do it pretty
well, but you probably shouldn't have to
train it that long.
I don't know. I I think Pac-Man might be
a surprisingly challenging problem. Kind
of on its own, like doable. But
the thing is the aisle is really good.
Like if this were like a year ago, sure.
But like now it's like the RL is really
freaking good.
Yeah, it's definitely doable. I will say
that it could be that our there could be
jank in the latest hyper sweep or
something because like we're having some
difficulty getting it to really truly
max out in a like small number of runs,
but like when it does find really good
hypers, it's like it's just
GG. the
um but to answer the question about the
obser current observations
um everything that you can pick up on
the map is a one hot. Um so it's like
it's a it's a a one if there is a thing
there and it's a zero if there is not a
thing there. Um but the ghosts and the
Asian are handled differently.
Um, so the the ghosts are the absolute
position of the ghost and then it's the
absolute position of the agent. Um, and
then there's a few other random one hots
in there like if a ghost can move in a
direction that's onehotted. Um, so like
north, south, east, west. Um, if a ghost
is scared,
that's a one hot. Yeah, the apps
positions are the sketchiest thing. You
have it normalized at least.
It is normalized between
zero and one. Okay, that's based on the
map size. Yeah. Yeah. I mean
relativizing
position be
good. Hey Spencer, based on this thing
here,
like we could totally do drone stuff if
we wanted to out of this, right?
Yeah, 100%. We just got to make sure
things don't hit each other.
All right, I'm going to do that at some
point. I got to get this dumb release
done. It's driving me
nuts. There just so many like shitty
experiments and things to check.
Yeah, I'm hoping that after the latest
sweep, I should have like pretty god
tier GPU drive params on a fixed set of
maps. And then I still got to somehow
figure out why resampling is like not
working,
but I know it shouldn't be like an issue
on a fixed set. Fix set is going to be
like for sure 100%
solved because I got one set of maps
that got to like 999 and like 0.002 or
something like that. Like it was like
good enough.
watch. I uh I really like your your
snake, too. The multi-agent snake. Snake
is really cool. Yeah, it's uh it's a lot
of fun to watch that one.
I was thinking about doing a continuous
version of it as well. It would just be
like substantially harder to make that
fast, I believe.
What do you mean by continuous here?
Like continuous positions like the
positions here are
Gotcha. Like oh man, like the merging
behavior on these is so cool. like how
they like split and
merge. So
cool. And just like the fact that they
have a turning
radius, you get like all these like
knots and
stuff and like occasionally half the
half of the one color of puffers end up
in one spot and half end up in another
and then they end up merging.
Almost makes me think of well like a
school of fish, you know. Well, it is a
school of fish. Yeah.
Um, do you have predators in that? Like
I see it's school of fish, but like you
should put predators in there.
Some swarming. It's just fish that are
attempting to go to the the uh star that
matches their color and then they change
color when they get it.
Okay. I was going to say put like a
dolphin in there and they have to avoid
dolphins too.
like Captain's suggestion to have the
goals move around was a really good
one cuz it like produces just these
really different patterns.
I got to get the puffer model like the
3D file. We could do this in 3D.
probably not much harder in 3D.
Make it an actual puffer tank. Yeah,
you gave this one continuous uh
positions, right? Yep.
Discrete actions for continuous
positions.
Right. Right. Right.
And then
uh what was your vision like on this?
It's really easy. It's like really
basic. You just do you just do relative
position of star? They just see the
relative position of each like the
closest of each color of star.
The closest of each color. Okay.
So basically all they have to learn
right they have to learn to match like
to map their color to star and then the
non-trivial part is that they have to
drag that like like simple onestep
inference over the much longer pathing
horizon that make
sense like I don't understand so like
actually pathing to the goal is like a
manystep process right Sure.
The making the decision like the
decision of like I am X color so I
choose X goal is a one-step decision.
So, it's like a kind of an interesting
thing where they have to like learn this
decision and then they have to follow
through on it with all the pathing
[Music]
and then the fact that this just like
learns instantly with default hypers in
seconds. And just naturally with the
turning radius and the variation, you
get like
these and
Like you you even get like a little bit
of separation even though there's no
reward for
separation. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I wonder
what it would be like if you decided to
add
a I don't know, like a
nearest if you're too close to a fish
penalty, too.
Yeah. I mean, then I would actually have
to do some engineering to make it fast
because then it gets like N squared with
a ton of fish.
That's an Nbody problem. Yep.
That's something else. Well, can't you
make it fairly fixed and just check like
five around you or something like that?
Uh, you have to make it so that you can
only have a fixed number occupying each
cell or something, but then Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Do that. Yeah. Yeah. Because
that's what I do on uh I do fixed
occupied
arrays for GPU drive stuff. Yeah. This
is a lot denser though with the number
of agents.
Sure. Sure. I mean, you have like a
thousand agents.
Yeah. And this is one of those things
where like it just looks cooler the more
agents you have. So like if I were to
have like a zoomed out version of this
in 3D, it might want to be like 8,000
agents. I wonder if
the policy
entropy controls the spread or if it's
related to spread.
like just like a little bit a little bit
of variability and and how the policy
well they kind of move like fish as well
because like the control is like they
can only turn in certain
increments. So they actually if you like
look at them they kind of like wobble
around a little like fish
sense. Came out very nicely.
What would be really satisfying is like
if you're able to make this interactive
somehow through the human side. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm going to do that at some
point. I'll make it so like can like
click and drag all the fish to you or
something. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's exactly what I was going for.
Yeah. Or like you can like right click
and like the fish will swim away from
you.
I don't know. Maybe we just maybe there
is like a game in this, you know? Maybe
we could actually ship a Steam game
that's just like the world's best fish
tank simulator.
Fish tank. You just you just feed the
fish and they like it's like just like a
school of fish, right?
I feel like there's a steam game
somewhere in in in a end. I think
there's there's opportunity there. It's
just a matter of which which end it was
most interesting.
I think one thing about RL for games,
which like maybe there's a solution to,
but like if if your goal is to train an
opponent to a human player using
RL, how do you keep it at the right
level of
difficulty? Because you don't want it to
be too good because that's not fun. You
don't want the human just to get stomped
every time. Like it's got a I mean to be
honest like there's so much dumb [ __ ]
you could do with that. Like you could
literally just like go back five
checkpoints every time they uh they lose
and go forward Yeah. and just go forward
five checkpoints every time they win.
That makes sense. There's so much dumb
stuff you could do for that.
What's funny is that's like a much
simpler solution as opposed to doing
some type of like it's so much simpler
online selfplay or some [ __ ] Yeah,
like just just train a good model and
give it a bad checkpoint.
I mean that's I guess chess AI sort of
has the same problem of like these are
like heavily nerfed algorithms.
Chess is hard.
Yeah. And chess AI is so good at this
point that like for it to be fun for a
human,
it just has to be at like I beat Tes the
Tesla easy
computer. The easiest setting of
one. No. No. No one. No one cares. All
right. Well, I know. I'm freaking
terrible at chess. Okay. I'm terrible at
like almost all games. I'm terrible,
too. Yeah. Yeah, I'm I mean I'm not good
at chess,
but I um I think even like the best
player in the world, right, couldn't
match the best chess AI. Definitely not.
No, that's already been proven. I mean,
I'm pretty sure Magnus like regularly
tied it.
I was going to say I'm pretty sure it's
already been
done, but like
his ELO is
like 2500. I think
2500's not that good.
I mean, there's still opportunity to do
the to do the first person shooter one,
Joseph, with uh with Brandon. Brandon.
Yeah. Brandon. Well, this just got a 70
and 35 randomly, so we'll see how this
goes. That's definitely fiddly.
Even Magnus Carlson acknowledges
superiority of
engines. Yeah. I think I think chess is
just so like searchable, right? The
problem just lends itself so well to
search. Yeah, it is a searchable, isn't
it?
I mean a human can't like the smartest
person can't look ahead that many moves.
It's just not similarly it's not
possible. The fastest human cannot play
Starcraft as quickly as yes a good
Starcraft playing computer.
Right. Certain certain inherent
advantages are afforded by the game
design. Humans should not really
be good at that kind of thing. I
am. I saw another like really cool ant
sim on uh YouTube earlier
today and it really convinced me like
they weren't even doing anything
sophisticated. It's like it's actually
really convinced me that this form stuff
is just easy and like basically all the
multi- aent stuff I was trying to do um
seven years ago it was actually totally
reasonable and just didn't work because
our infrastructure sucked.
That might make sense.
That actually might be a good thing to
think about as well, Spencer. Like like
specifically multi-agent problems
because those are going to be the ones
where people have failed the hardest
before.
That's going to be your your instead of
just putting the dirt down, you're going
to have dump trucks that come and take
it away.
I mean, that would just straight up
work.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah, I I got to think
about like what what subsets of
industries benefit most from multi- aent
type problems.
Well, the thing is you have to get a
little flexible with what an agent
is. I think
uh details
well like technically these puffers
like if you consider each star is like a
resource, right? Then the puffers are
like and the puffers are like just
routing resource like one to another.
These could be like delivery bots. I
mean they can approximate freaking
conveyor belts like Yeah. Yeah. I see
what you're saying.
That's the factorial of right. I mean,
I've been playing Satisfactory. Yo,
Spencer, the uh the non-automated
factory idea turned out to just be
incredibly stupid. At least the way I
did it was incredibly stupid. So,
lo and behold,
I won't share that concept with them.
Yeah,
what was that concept? The concept was I
just made I made like a bunch of modules
where it's like the same module and all
it does is it has a bunch of containers
where you put in inputs and a bunch of
containers where the outputs go and like
but the thing is it doesn't actually
like route to any other module. So the
idea was just that like you have each
thing build a ton of one thing and then
every so often you just manually move
the outputs to the inputs of the
whatever the next thing is and then like
you can just reuse modules for like
making whatever one thing that you want.
Um yeah, that idea sucked for a few
reasons. One of which is a bug in in the
game which causes the conveyor belt to
jam uh when you do that. So that one's
not on me. Yeah, there's a bug that
caused the conveyor belts to jam. And uh
the other thing was just that like you
need a lot of input materials to get
this whole thing started. So for a long
time you're just like manually moving
like a few stacks and you're just kind
of like running around for a long time
to get the thing started. Um, and it's
also like really easy to like the
modules are big, so it's actually pretty
difficult to keep track of like what
each of your 16 modules or whatever is
doing at any one time.
Uh, you say you're just making a factory
that is not automated. Yeah, that was
the idea. What? Interesting. Well, the
thing is because otherwise you have to
like get all these dumb ratios right
from like one machine to the next
machine or and like the thing that was
cool is I basically I've had to like it
it I got around that because they didn't
all get routed like directly together.
You actually didn't have to really worry
about the ratios much at all.
Uh interesting.
Is satisfactory on Mac? I don't think it
is. Yeah, you're a real OS man.
I do. It works on Linux. I just need to
put more thermal paste on my computer at
home. Yeah. Oh,
it's actually kind of impressive how
like everything pretty much just runs on
Linux now off of Steam.
Yeah. Well, it's become pretty back in
the day there was not much. I I wouldn't
go that. Not everything. It's pretty
good, right? It's obviously on
everything, but it's Oh, but they're
very very intentionally. The best part
about Linux is that it doesn't run
League or Valerant, so I can't become
completely addicted.
Yeah, it's not not Yeah, that's because
of colonel level anti-che,
which should not exist. That should not
be a thing. I mean, it shouldn't that
that being said, you know, the probably
the reason is more so like people who
use Linux don't buy skins. So,
uh, I I've given Yeah, that's not true.
Like, yeah, I think so. You think you
think it's the opposite? You know, I
like I played Valerant for like three
months and I probably gave him like 300
bucks. That's it. 300 in three months.
It's pretty damn good. Pretty good ROI
on their on
amateur numbers.
Hey, I don't know. It was like I got
like a dollar. It's like a dollar an
hour of out of entertainment for a game
I liked. I was like, "All right, I'm
happy to do that." Yeah, I know, right?
That's a bad justification, though. I
just You can justify anything with like
that. I mean, actually, they didn't get
the thing that they didn't get much out
of me. They didn't get anything out of
me for League Pretty much cuz like
the cosmetics are just bad. Yeah. What's
the point of buying, you know, buying
skins for champs you can't play?
Unlocking the champs you again can't
play.
Like here's what you should be able to
unlock. Like good camera controls.
I actually proposed that to them. I
actually proposed to them like rlinging
the camera control. We should just do
it. It would totally
That's just skill issue. Sorry guys.
Yeah, it is not. Well, it is. But yeah,
it is, dude. It is. But I I specifically
proposed it because it's like like just
like I plus RL the camera control of
like pro players modulo keep camera with
your character on screen. Um and then
like everyone from like iron to flat is
no longer super pissed about having to
like fight the camera instead of their
opponent and then everyone above that
does it manually anyways. Yeah. Turns
out people, you know, league players are
actually saints, but they're they
they're just, you know, pretty pretty
torn between having to micromanage the
camera constantly and then actually play
the game as well. They they still don't
have anything left to, you know, be
nice. Are you kidding me? The League
community is Have you like played an
MMO? Man, the League community is a
bunch of angels compared to that.
Really? Oh, yeah. I disagree. I've had a
roommate that plays
I've had a roommate that plays League of
Legends punch through my TV that he was
using to play it. I have never once seen
my other roommate break anything because
he died playing Runescape.
Ah, yeah. Well, the thing the trick here
is Linky is that he probably doesn't PK
in RS. Yeah. Does that like those guys?
No, that's like he plays old school PK.
That is the only way he plays. Oh man.
Yeah, those people are like
those people. I can't even say [ __ ]
anymore on Twitch or like YouTube cuz
it's immediate demonetized. But like
yeah, you can't even you can't even like
you can't even paraphrase the [ __ ] they
say because it's it's I don't even think
it's demonetized. I think you just
straight up get banned.
I will say he says a lot of off-the-cuff
things. I will agree to that. But he's
never once punched through a screen.
Whereas I had another guy literally he
broke his laptop screen playing League
of Legends. So I let him use my TV.
Broke that and then he straight up
straight through the TV too. I was like,
"Bro, this is why we can't have nice
things." Yeah. Totally my fault. Yeah.
for having a roommate like that.
It's pretty nuts.
All right. Well, we're going to see what
the hell this uh sweep does. I'm not
super optimistic, but maybe it's gotten
a few decent runs. It'll get solved.
We also have the neural MMO run going
and I like tomorrow we're going to get
the servers in. It'll be good. Um, it's
just so many fiddly bits, man, to like
get this release ready. We have good
hypers for most of the environments
already. Yo, bet. Can you figure out why
connect four segs at some point? You got
time? It doesn't say full for me. So,
oh, what's the dang puffer box? I'll
I'll I'll get a puffer box and I will
try to make it fault, but I I tested
extensively.
Uh, so you know what? I messaged you
about that pretty. Uh, did you? Can you
can you reproduce? You want to repo that
for me right now so I can see
right? I'm going through all the
simulator games on Steam to see which
one would be worthy of replicating.
Knockoff. I mean, make better. Yeah.
Yeah. Knockoff. Exactly. Oh yeah, there
you go.
Right there. That was it. Huh?
Just instantly. You have latest hypers.
Yeah. Yes. Cuz you said that before then
I pulled them down and then it still
turned fine. So
uh and um Okay. Let me What are you on?
Do you get branch for me?
correct. Get branch get fetch for
me. I say lit
literally. You never know. I know you
don't run crazy multiple virtual
environments and such. All right. Get
fetched. Yeah, I'm assuming you don't
have any remote other remotes. All
right, fine. It's legit.
Uh, yeah. So, I mean that Yeah, that
change that's that's strange why it's
seg faulting.
though. Trying to trying to think does
uh Evo work for you? I was going to say,
are you running it on your AMD computer
and bet is attempting to run it on
Intel? Like could that I know that's a
stretch, but could that affect it?
Maybe.
Yeah, exactly. Maybe. There we go. Yeah.
Could you fix that while we're
No, that's that's just a thing. The No,
the config bug. What config bug? That
That's not a config bug. That's a seg
fault.
Wait, wait. So, you're saying that that
error you got about the config was not a
config bug. What? This? No. Yeah.
Scroll. I I You're not streaming, so I
have to wait for the stream to catch up.
Yeah. Yeah. There's no config for name
Connect 4 because there's no Connect 4.
It's Puffer Connect 4.
Okay. All right. Yeah, know that's that
turn when you did puffer correct for it
worked. Yeah, eval puffer connect for
that guy.
Oh, that guy's here
too. Yeah,
being sad because he's bottlenecked by
CPUs even though we have multiGPU boxes
coming. Two over five. Yeah. Okay. I
mean, can anyone else want to pull down
connect 4? See if you can repo the the
fault sig falter. If anybody
does I mean, I can technically like
Well, my box is running a sweep and my
desktop's running a sweep. Yeah, I'll
just Yeah, you could probably still run
it. I mean, I could pull real quick, but
I'm all Maybe it works out because I'm
on AMD as well. There you go. See,
I'm there's power wash simulator.
What branch do I need to be on?
3.0.
What branch do I 0.5 branch? My boys
kind of like C in the sense that Syon,
but not kind of like C in the sense that
it's like really freaking slow.
What's
slow? that Pi Boy is because it not
because the code is slow, but because
it's an emulator on the game. Yeah,
because it's emulated. Yeah. Need a
native
I How hard is it to write like if you
were to just like try to write something
that can run ROMs in a way that like
doesn't exactly emulate the hardware but
still works? Is that a thing you can do?
Uh there's a there's a C++ plus run
Pokemon blue red only emulator
So actually yo I was thinking of what if
you just took that and then ported that
like 100 line one to CUDA. Can you do
that? Yo that hey that guy would that
actually work if you just took like the
100 line emulator and like pasted it
into CUDA? I know it's I mean and then
just like numbum threads equals num m
work? No
clue. You spent a lot of time optimizing
the thing. Maybe that's like the way to
go is you just freaking
codes. Well, the point is that you're
not really emulating a CP. You're
emulating a ridiculously slow CPU,
right? But then like you have a bunch of
threads because you're running the same
emulator. So like you would run like 4K
copies of Pokemon.
Is there anything in the security field
we could use RL for? Yeah, there were
actually people that were like trying to
use RL to like simulate or like pen nest
networks or some [ __ ] Yeah,
I'm going to have to gro that concept. I
don't I'm I'm not really certain how
that would have no idea. Am I robotic
right now?
I don't know like 10% robotic.
They're using they're trying to use AI
to do like uh pen testing currently.
There's actually a CVE that was found
when they were experimenting it. I can't
remember the library though.
Pull down.
Yeah, but that's not that much data.
That guy, you plant a few plant a few uh
uh vulnerabilities and then you know
give it a reward when it finds them.
I don't exactly know the ins and outs of
it because I realistically didn't read
too much into it. All I know is
someone purposefully put a bug into some
well-known library and was trying to
sanity check the LLM or whatever model
thing they were training to try and
test, hey, can it find a vulnerability?
missed the one that they purposefully
put in there but found an actual um an
actual issue in in there. Okay. So, it's
this actually it's this bottom function.
So, for some reason this bit mask is
messing up
bit mask used to Oh, is this in the
connect four or
Oh, this is the adjusted connect 4 since
I haven't touched this in like a million
years.
You're not You're not even bandwidth
bound anyways that guy, right? You're
like SIM bound, aren't
bound. You shouldn't get bandwidth bound
until you've got like gigabytes a
second. That's just because it's not
super well
optimized. Should get to tens of gigs.
brain question. How do I do the build in
place crap?
Uh, build in place dash
uh build setup.py buildex dash in place
d-force.
Yeah. Uh, yeah. So, this bit mask here
is like this is supposed to be a
constant.
Is that your
room? I mean, this is pretty much the
whole building minus uh minus my room.
I've got a shoulder fresh shoulder
injury and a longer knee injury.
Otherwise, I'd be doing I'd be getting
up to do sets every so often. Joseph,
last last thing I heard, you were like,
"Oh, my knee hurts. Can't do this. Can't
do that." But I can do these overhead
presses. Yeah. So, I It was kind of
awkward. Like I went I went to go do my
set and then there were randomly some
like workers just like literally with
their faces pressed up to my window like
oh look at the gym or whatever but it
was like kind of [ __ ] weird and it I
don't know it like threw me off or
something cuz like I picked up like some
like 60s or whatever which is should be
pretty light. Um and I don't know I just
I got off balance somehow and I like to
twerk my like shoulder. I had to drop it
from like seated overhead. Weird. I
Yeah. Yeah. And like the weirdest thing
about it is like right before that so I
had 60s. I had 110 on a
barbell. Um and it felt like like
literally like nothing. Like I could
have thrown that a few feet into the
air. 60s as in free weights, right? 60
some dumbbells. Yeah. Upright shoulder
press. But the thing is, I'd done 60s
the week before and it's like a little
unstable but easy. Oh, it's it's Yeah,
it's just shoulders are just Yeah,
people hurt their shoulders because
they're like kind of vulnerable muscles,
I'd say. I mean, it's they're just
undertrained a lot of the time. It's not
welcome to getting older. It's called
welcome to being lazy and not actually
working out.
You advanced your weight too quickly,
probably.
Yeah, he's right, too. You just wait,
Joseph. You'll see.
That's some
[ __ ] I I'm going to We'll just
pivot from solving RL to solving AJ
next.
Wait, what the hell did this Did this
just find god parameters?
Yeah. Yes, you you've solved the mystery
of I can report back
um connect is running.
Uhhuh.
I don't use container.
No, no, not you, Joseph.
The bottom returns this thing.
I mean, this returns a
thing, but it's still Seg faults on
this. You know
what is that right? That print. Okay.
Oh, I bet this run was just lucky. You
know what? I think I found it. Yeah, I
bet I found it.
Joseph, in my randomization of pearl and
noise, do I have to take into account
the fact that there's a chance that they
could make two pearl and noises that are
fairly similar to each other and I
should filter those out? Oh, god damn
it. That was the [ __ ] problem.
The same sameness random randomizer
check. Nice. Looks good. The the problem
was a [ __ ] name collision with
something in the Python library.
something in the Python C library.
Yeah, it's it's always sus when you when
you set up I noticed it. I was like,
"Wait a second. Wait a second. This says
bottom not in my code."
Give Leaky a pat on the back. Thank you,
Linky.
What I do? I I I I got him I got him to
do it though. He originate you're you
originated the C underscore fixing of
[ __ ]
That is that was the thing that guy that
it was bottom is yes it's like there's a
bottom in Python so or I don't know why
the hell namespace is like like that's
so dumb. Also don't know why is
everything global namespace.
It's
weird. Yeah, that that would actually be
consistent too with what we what we saw
with the Core. Honestly, when people say
like, "Oh, yeah, it's like C but better
or whatever," and they make like Rust or
Zigg, I want them to like not actually
fix all the [ __ ] that nobody asked them
to touch and just like fix the jank
stuff like this.
Yeah, I think these are kind of niche.
Like most people probably do not run
into it, but but like this is the thing.
Like that's all that's wrong with C are
like the niche annoying things.
Yeah, it's a it's a you know pretty
complete language.
It's like I wish that instead of like oh
it's it's like Z like Zig is like oh
it's C except C with like this and that
and this other thing that nobody [ __ ]
asked for. It's like Rust is like C but
with memory management that nobody
[ __ ] asked for unless they don't
understand like how the free easy like
you know I've heard this same exact
argument until people are red in the
face with the uh Java versus Cotlin. I
mean it's small nuances that piss some
people off.
Yeah, those just both mangle the single
table to add puffer underscore
all your fun. But then I have to call
them with puffer underscore, don't I?
I mean, yeah, you call them with puffer
underscore, but then you strip them when
you actually call them in your
environment. For the environment. So
it's like
I did box internet crash at all. Did box
internet crash when? just now. I don't
know within the last few minutes. Let's
see here. I'll tell you right now. Uh it
shouldn't have because it's literally
with me and like it's literally in the
same room with me. It's possible that
Neptune has been janked though. It's
working. Yeah, my connection to my
Neptune server was lost and then the
sweep died. Neptune's getting I think
Neptune's getting to be uh kind of jank
lately to be honest. They're having
their AOL moment. Too many too many CDs.
Too many users. I will restart sweep and
we'll see close.
This rip the GPU drive sweep and that
sweep takes like I tried to deliver A+
hacks. A++ that guy.
Do I need to check the status of the
boxes real quick?
It's a No, they're fine. And my my
things have been fine as well. It looks
like and be I just have a
script at Huffer and biases, dude. Like
the thing is it's the dumbest company to
start cuz you're basically just selling
your shitty overpriced Electron app to
ML researchers for ludicrous prices and
like hoping that somehow makes sense.
Um, but the thing is like if I wanted to
do it for the hell of it, yes, like I
could very easily like I could just make
some dumb rail UI and it would actually
be good because like it wouldn't lag for
10 seconds or whatever whenever like
look at this
[ __ ] or here like if I go to like 200
graphs, man, 200 points is like that's a
lot of points. Let's wait for the data.
Let's wait for the data.
Uh, wait for the data. Wait for the
data. There. There's
the app.
Yeah. Now, I'm not saying we should
switch to TensorBoard by any means. I've
tried it. Not my shindig. But we should
be looking
for
local local tools instead of relying on
like an app or you know website or
anything because now you're just
introducing like more latency not only
sending and receiving data but also like
load times. It's the [ __ ] UI like it's
just it's not almost no data. It's just
the [ __ ] UI.
It's like 200 It's literally it's 200
lines on a graph. Like you could just
like if you just did that in array lib
like literally plotting the lines one
pixel at a time it would be faster than
this.
Oh I know. I at one point was doing bar
graphs for the puffer box status so you
could see like the time scale over seven
days. Way quicker to plot it. And I mean
I'm iterating over
uh every five minutes it takes a data
point for seven days. So that's
like I mean 10 11 12 *
7 for every box and it it's just way
faster. Yeah. The crazy like the crazy
thing about that is just like if you
think about how stupid you're allowed to
be, it's like hacking stuff in C. Like
you can be really stupid about how you
do stuff, right? The fact that all of
modern software is like a tenth of that
speed means they've really [ __ ] up.
Yeah. Yeah. I see here
I think
it's people fighting legacy code. I mean
turnover
newish companies. It's it's not legacy
code. It's like actually the legacy code
is fine. It's the new code by [ __ ] devs.
I shouldn't. So legacy sound, it's maybe
misinterpreted here. I mean, you hire an
intern, you tell your interns, hey,
write this. We need it. Fix it. That
intern now leaves. Another intern comes
in and they go, hey, we found a bug. Fix
it. So that's what I mean by legacy. You
just have so many people that weren't
the originators and started all this and
they just throw bodies at it assuming
it'll work and then because nobody has a
total view of like the entire project
then they're just like ah we'll just
band-aid everything together.
The features that get dollars are not
the simple features. I'm pretty sure
that like having a UI that doesn't lag
for three seconds whenever you click a
button pretty damn high up on the list
of features want
I actually like next to no features
that's from that's from that guy's
comment that yeah link you're not
reading the chat that guy suggests using
an ML flow server uh it's jank but it
works as I basically don't want any
features as a thing I want a basic ass
thing that actually works
It's not a hyper. I just want data
plotted. Yeah. Yeah, I can do that. I
mean, you can you can do whatever you
want with it, your data, right? Why not
graph?
I mean, Graphfana Prometheus together is
like a solid pipeline in my experience.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, I don't know what
your average researcher uses one or
Neptune for, but I'm guessing it's
different than what what we're doing.
It's probably some weird like
somehow weirdly integrated use or other
other thing that we include LLMs
therefore doesn't matter. Ah yes I
forgot LLMs like you yes it's LMS are
different because actually you want your
plots for your LLM data to lag for as
long as possible.
My bad. I I totally forgot. Since LLMs
are so slow, you want your UI to be
super slow, of course.
It's also worth questioning, is the
latency like the actual data being
plotted or is it your connection to
what's plotting it? It's not my
connection to what's plotting it. You
could you could easily test that though,
right?
Yeah, you could test it. You could you
could just self-host your your own
server or whatever, too.
But uh I do. Yeah. No, I mean like your
own wannabe Neptune, etc.
Yeah.
Like
it it it ends up being a uh you know,
probably a pretty significant time sync.
Nah, plotting data is really
not too terrible. I mean, again, I did
it, granted it was Python, but I did it
for the
boxes. Like, I have manual data
plotting, UI generating for Pokemon as
well.
Yeah, I haven't gotten that far, but
that's because
I I mean the visualizer map is it kind
of tells you where where shit's at. Oh,
yeah. It's a that's, you know, a very
useful lightweight integration. I got to
go to bed, guys. It is getting late.
It's time. Rest up. Rest up those uh
body parts. RS's actually care about or
work with.
Did I hear RS? Research
scient like research scientist no good
software if it hit him in the face dude.
Like I've
got
Yeah.
Like it's like they ask for like
it's like faster horses like X a
billion.
Um, it's like, oh yeah, Jax is so good
because now we can continue to write
Python but like have it run on. It's
when we just needed to be able to write
loops in any language that wasn't
Python. It's just dumb as [ __ ] Anyways,
I am going to bed before I yell at more
clouds. I'm apparently an old man yells
at clouds arc.
Uh, I don't know. Get off my cloud.
Yeah, get Yeah, you know, get off. Get
That's what it's going to be. not get
off my loudness and get off my cloud.
Yeah. All right. Um, no. Like, I don't
know. Lately, I've just been thinking
it's like that just all software written
in the last 20 years just wrapped and
redone.
Yeah. Anyways, not not with utility in
mind. So, anyways, I'm uh yeah, I'm
going to sleep. Uh, we're going to hope
that this run does something. It's not
necessarily blocking cuz like it still
beeps. This is really, this one has
really hard to perfectly fine-tune
hypers. Uh, we'll keep iterating. I'll
keep looking for this. I have the exact
diffs for this. Uh, we got DDP working
roughly linear speed up on 8x800 uh,
8x800s today. We have 16, no 12 490s
arriving tomorrow. Um, so get those set
up. Probably start on some stuff for
that. We'll do maybe some other fixes
and uh yeah, few more experiments to go
for. Thanks, folks.